HEY WHAT'S GOING ON IS BILL BYRNE It's time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday August 7th Lucky 7 2017.
What's going on dude.
He yell.
He said seven I thought seven.
And then he yelled lucky seven.
Dude I'm going to play that fucking number.
Dude I'm going down to Christie's and get me a fuckin set for life getting seven
of them.
I can fucking hear myself I'm screaming loud enough.
You know people when you're not talented what you have to do is yell.
You know believe that.
Watch my fucking list.
Fuck it whatever I mean.
I don't know how many special I've done you know when you talk in the amount of
shit I do why can't I hear myself the way I want to hear myself.
Why can't I hear me the way I used to.
Am I going deaf.
So what's going on.
Has that said too much.
Hello.
Test 1 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2.
The fuck is with this thing.
Do I have an hour on some sort of fucking parental mode.
You know hearing lions is one of the number one causes of hearing loss in 2017
because these ear buds that are all the rage with the children
I actually had time today to go over and go play drums today and I put on a
fucking HDD clinic.
Jesus Christ I like practice nine thousand things get better at nothing.
That's how I practice a let's do double bass for two minutes.
Eh let's work on singles and doubles.
Let's do the jazz right.
I was talking to some born triplets right.
Just kept going and going.
But you know what.
I didn't sound that bad.
I had a good time.
I fucking love that kid though.
I had a small setup.
You guys gave me shit cause I had fucking three floor times legos.
Would you do it will bore you for good reason.
You fucking to pay.
I don't own a toupee.
All right.
You can own a toupee.
It just let you know what I mean.
I've thought.
I bet they make them really good right now.
But it would just be like wearing this fucking hat.
You could never take off.
You know you wake up in the morning and you get your little roller.
You know what the glue.
You know you just fucking go on over your scalp.
You know you're doing that your wife comes walking in.
I mean Jesus Christ.
I mean she's gonna be bangin another guy within three days.
If you're a fucking woman walks in while you're gluing hair to the top of your
head all right.
And she doesn't leave you.
That woman is a saint.
You know what I mean.
I love the guys who have like the fucking the toupee and then they can't even
get like the like the decides to match it.
You don't know me.
It's like dude are you fucking colorblind.
Do you really think that that that's blending into what you got on the sides.
You know it's funny to us when you go down the toupee road
they don't.
I don't know.
As far as I know they don't make any white ones.
Like if you're an older guy so then you gotta dye the shit you got on the side.
All right.
So then it just makes people look at your head like you just like this guy's
like 60.
How does he have Jet Blue now.
Good Lord look at that fucking thing.
JJ
You know I don't like about toupees.
Actually hair plugs now is they're too good now.
Used to be it used to be able to tell.
And you could really fuck somebody up and conversation going to do.
I don't give a fuck how smart they were to do it.
Just kind of look up at it and then look back at him and then they were just
fucked for the rest of the conversation and those days are gone now because they
got to god damn good at it.
So anyways I was playing you know playing all the drums shit and at this point
because my drum teacher is out on the road I haven't been taking any lessons you
know drum teacher David Lynch out with the night game
opening for Dave.
Now that I said Dave Matthews No John Mayer.
Opening for John Mayer was Steve Jordan on drums.
Jesus Christ.
You get to see David Lynch and then you get to see Steve Jordan how about that.
It there's a fucking evening for you know
that be enough forget God damn millennials.
Yeah.
So I haven't been taken lessons but so I just it's actually kind of been a good
thing because I can go back to all the shit that I never fucking got down that
he showed me while developing new bad habits.
But I know can.
Anyways I'm having a great time.
So people give me shit cause I got the three floor times but this is why I did
it.
This was the method to my madness.
All right I got 12 inch racked and I got a 14 16 18 floor top so and then a
twenty two kick.
Right.
So
I hate having to rack times but I ended up ordering another one so I got to
twelve I got thirteen come in so now I can go bigger small people bigger smaller
I need to go 12 14 16 or 13 16 18 depending on whatever the fuck and whatever
song I'm going to go butcher on the god damn comedy chair all right.
Why can't I just have a hobby.
Without people criticizing it why can't people just say Hey nice drum kit that
dude what do you going to do.
Fucking Floyd talk for a guy just to give.
Jesus I don't know
I'm trying to get out of fucking the bottom
death spin.
I went on for fucking 30 years I'm just trying a different setup.
That's all I was doing.
Get more goddamn shit for that.
That and saying new killer instead of new clear.
You know I love the word police you know to me it's just like where are you
going gonna get in life with that.
You know it's not new killer it's nuclear.
I've always said no killer
always said it it sounds right to me rolls off the tongue a little bit easier
than nuclear.
It's a nuclear weapon not nuclear.
Laughing my ass off.
Let me ask you this.
Where are you laughing your ass off.
Where exactly are you in your fucking life.
Because as dumb as I am I'm doing all right.
You know is there is there a fucking job that you can do where you dot all your
eyes cross all your T's and correct spelling or you can be I guess a teacher.
Is that what it is.
Do I have a bunch of teachers following me on Twitter.
I don't know why they would
you know.
Good lord these fucking people they're always like there's so much shit ISIS a
Palo instead of pillow get the palace after fucking 2.
I mean I you know just shit you just say in a different way.
Because does that mean you don't know what the fuck you put your head on at
night.
Where does it get you
can you make a living doing crossword puzzles.
Those are those kinds of.
They're good at the so do q is Sudoku ever the fuck you say that Sudoku doodle
go for go right there they've got a dead shit
dude she's really smart she can do the New York Times she can do the New York
Times crossword puzzle.
Great.
Fantastic.
Where does that get you.
Where does it get you in life.
I mean I don't know.
I mean tell me Tell me how that's holding me back.
That's what I want to know and I know I'm kind of harping on this but it's like
the 900 word you guys have fucking correct me on it.
I don't give a shit.
I like nucular sounds like it's more fucking like the missiles spinning a little
bit more clear like new clear.
It's Kiki clear Here it comes.
New killers.
Well it's a little shoulder roll in their new killer.
I like I'm keeping it.
Fuck off
you know do you guys like right fucking Jayce every time he says Ho when you
like.
Actually it's.
Or laughing my ass off.
I bet you don't right because you're liberals
you know but you give a white male fucks up and what do you do.
You'll hold my fuckin alabaster feet to the fire.
Don't you I've had a little bit and I've had enough of it all right.
I've had enough of people trying to make me not out like I'm ashamed of how
stupid I am.
I'm not OK.
I saw the carrot man and I walked towards it.
I knew what I was good at.
I knew being a loud mouth fucking moron was what I was good at and I just did
that.
OK I'm not going to ever be in a classroom teaching people how to spell or
pronounce shit.
OK so let it go.
This ship has sailed.
There's no hope for me.
All right.
But you know what the thrill is the real reason people they're not doing it for
me.
They're doing it for them to show how smart they are.
Oh it's not total.
It's Turtle.
Laughing my ass off.
I know how to say that fucking amphibians name.
Oh actually it's not even a fit.
We are stopping.
It's not an amphibious amphibian his humility.
SHUT THE FUCK
YOU WHAT DOES WHAT ARE THOSE PEOPLE THEY practicing to be on a game show.
Is that what it is.
That's like the smart way a person plays the lottery I guess right.
The lottery you just could be a dope like me.
Go on.
Don't you see that nucular weapon.
And then you go and let me get a fuckin set for life right.
That's how I try to make it okay.
This smarty pants who can do the fucking who can actually do that New York Times
crossword puzzle is now you know trying to get on like Wheel of Fortune because
you know that's like the fucking dumbest crossword you can do whatever the fuck
does it is a crossword.
No it isn't right.
It's like yes the letters it looks like a crossword but it is.
But I just love that you will be smart enough to do the New York Times crossword
puzzle and then still you're going to get on there right and you've got to spin
a wheel
and spin that wheel.
There's no intelligence.
You just spin it.
You can be the smartest person on the world and you're going to roll loser turn.
Bankrupt and it's fucking over.
I like watching Jeopardy when you know there's somebody just you just can't
defeat this guy and all these other smarty pants get on there and their whole
life.
They were the fuckin smartest one you know.
You know those people that don't like drink
and they'd like they play board games like let's play Trivial Pursuit.
You know what I mean.
Let's let's play whatever those fucking games I have to tell you
some of the saddest moments in my adult life as I've gone to parties and all of
a sudden a breakout board games and
you ever see like when somebody is on hidden video and they start looking around
like What the fuck and the crowd starts laugh like that's the look on my face
like that and then I'm going to do this.
They're not doing this other does this everybody have to play.
I don't wanna do this.
I don't wanna fucking do one of my five year old
you know are we trapped in a fucking cabin and then there is no television.
No.
This is crude.
You can connect pretty I'll play some cards.
You know I like how cards is like the only other cards it's just like there's a
sleazy vibe to cards that I've always enjoyed even though I don't play a lot of
cards.
But you know even like those fucking old ladies seen some old lady with their
bony fingers fucking shuffle and not even look and talk and some shit.
She's got a favorite little candies right to the right you know in a dish.
You know I saw an old school old lady today I was in I was down at the grocery
store buying some fuckin food right.
And this lady comes around the corner she add on like this turquoise blazer with
like some sort of brooch.
I forget what she had underneath it.
She had white slacks on white shoes and a white purse.
Just old school dress to the fucking night she look great.
Total fucking class act
made me miss my grandmother.
My grandmother was a sharp dresser.
They think those people they knew how to fuckin dress you know what I mean and
then they did buy a pair of shoes.
God
damn it they took care of
not like us today you know.
Well every black person I knew there was took care of their fucking sneakers.
You know what I mean.
Keep the fucking things look brand new.
You know taken out a god damn you know the nail brush scrub in the sides right.
There was another white privilege moment right now you could just have dirty
sneakers and that was OK.
Me and I went outside and you got dirty and you keep watching me just.
He's always gonna be dirt out here man.
I mean when Patrice just give me shit for my sneakers being dirty I was just
like
a fucking beauty pageant.
He's like Bill if you were black and you walked out.
I mean I'm not black.
This is totally socially acceptable for me.
I get it.
You have new sneakers on.
Congratulations.
Anyways I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
I'm doing this this Sunday night because as always I have a million things to do
during this time of year as we're writing
Season 3 3 3 of episode family family family.
We're going to be recording Episode 3 and writing episode 4 this week.
Big shit going we're almost at the clubhouse turn here now it's actually the guy
coming down the backstretch.
You know I think we'll have five.
Written and recorded by the end of this this month.
And I know what you guys are thinking.
So what does that mean.
It comes out December.
Oh no.
No there's like 40 different other things you have to do to it over the course
of the next.
I don't know how many months before it finally fucking comes out.
I have no idea.
We were joking one time I think by the time we do the sixth season I'll be in my
late 60s
but I have to tell you I really fucking like it.
I really like doing it and
I really enjoy being in the writers room you know.
Some days it sucks when like this shit just doesn't work and my brain isn't
working and I'm fried some of those days suck but generally but then you know
and everybody else is
saying funny shit so that makes you get going you know.
But I actually really enjoy writing dialogue.
Who would have thought you know in a way I can.
You know some guy who says nucular can actually write a fucking episode of
television you know just think about that.
Okay.
Think about think about that and then stop complaining about who is president
right now.
Okay.
If you can say nucular and then you can fuck me.
George Bush you say nucular the amount of people that fuckin laughed at him and
I want to be like Hey are you bilingual.
Can you also speak Spanish.
Did you go to Yale.
The guy went to fucking Yale.
All right.
I don't give a shit if his dad got him into what is a legacy.
He still went there.
You still got that education.
Still gonna be a member of the skull and bones.
I think it's why I had that laugh because he knew we didn't belong there.
He knew he got his feet just got pushed down that fucking road you know.
Well you think he really wanted to do.
I think like what you do after your prayers after President really lets people
know how much you love the job.
You know what I mean.
And like he just fucking desert Bill Clinton he still you know Bill Clinton was
all about the horse you know so he's still he's still out there giving speeches.
I don't know his fucking Dad's right.
He's still out there.
You know.
Jimmy Carter's is building fucking arms there now and then he got fuckin.
George Bush he's just he's fucking hanging out like a trust fund kid.
He's just sit around Peyton did you see that documentary rich kids like one of
the saddest fucking things I've ever seen in my life was
these people they were born into such wealth
like one of them was that they were part of the Johnson Johnson family which I
think a lot of people don't know what that is but like when I was growing up
everything was made by Johnson and Johnson.
I'm sure they got bought out whatever but when
I guess when they bought that out Johnson and Johnson they built it in that
their kids would always just be taken care of and would have a I don't know a
position that competent they would just get money is this fucking beast that
Johnson and Johnson built just the inertia of that fucking thing just tearing
through the capitalist economy right was just so big that they just think just
like if they get the skim member fucking casino the scam that their kids still
get the scam and the fuckin scam alone they get a little fucking duffle bag of
cash that they don't ever have to work in their life right.
And I would think that that would be too.
That would be the fucking greatest thing ever.
That would be the greatest thing ever.
And
it kind of turned out that it wasn't.
I think it would be the greatest thing ever if you actually.
Lived the other way first
but even then I think I think it'll get boring after a while.
Do you think you could do it.
I think if you just had enough money well you never had to work again.
My
thought would be well the next big thing in my life is I'm gonna die.
That's the next eventful thing.
I have no deadlines.
I have no worries
Oh my my.
I would get like Psycho obsessed with shit
you know.
Like I do already but then like my real life takes over.
I can play drums and lead once again for us.
I'm a fan of playing on fucking time and then like my real life to.
You get to go to the writers room and then it eases it off.
Like if I just fucking was sitting there like when I was talking to guys about
that building in Manhattan the one looks like a giant cigarette something Park
Avenue.
And I was like What the fuck is that thing that thing is bigger than the Freedom
Tower.
And I went back and I looked at those pictures that they have from the penthouse
in that building and that bathtub.
Bathtub everybody has now it's shaped like like the fucking Chicago Bears
stadium.
You know that one that freestanding one is not on legs like it's it's big.
The ladies love it evidently.
Right.
And it's right up on the fuckin window and you can just look out.
All the way south of Manhattan past the Statue of Liberty to see the fucking and
you know whenever the Germans come to attack us again.
Think you know
this person in the fucking tub is gonna see it first right.
The Japanese I should say.
I just figured that side of the country you know the Germans would be coming
right with their nuclear weapons.
Actually why would you bring it over here.
You just fucking shoot it off when you.
Anyway so I was just looking at and I was just trying to imagine sitting in that
tub taking a bath.
That would be one of the saddest experiences you could be could possibly have.
It looks so fucking lonely.
First when I saw I was like holy shit that's fucking unbelievable that looks
like.
Feel like I'm in a helicopter but you're like in a fuckin building.
But then just being that high up you can't even hear the city anymore.
Just how quiet it would be.
You know you lit it.
You're getting to that level that thing that astronauts see.
You know like the astronauts they would go out and they would orbit the earth
and they would just look down at it and they were above all the bullshit all the
politics all the religion all the fucking war all the disease all the suffering
and they looked down and they were able to see how beautiful it was the paradise
that we actually live in
we just sit here with all those petty shit and these guys would come back and
they couldn't talk to anybody about it couldn't give anybody else that
perspective unless they talked to a fellow astronaut.
So then they would just be you know pulling up to a stoplight.
They would see something they would just randomly start crying.
I think that would happen if I took a bath that high above fuckin Manhattan.
And you just looking out all.
Why can't why isn't.
Why don't we ever do the right to be philosophically just stay why don't we do
the right thing why are we always like you can't.
That's that's.
That's the scary thing it's what all pilots are a little fucking weird.
There's something weird about going up there and just looking down at all of it
you know like a higher being.
That you also get to see what the fuck would do into the planet.
It's a really fucking it's a weird thing.
And then you combine that with the fact that you'd taken a bath.
One of the most relaxing thing ever.
Just looking down at this fucking terror.
I don't know.
I also kind of wonder like with global warming like what's going to happen.
You know I'm sorry.
Climate change.
I didn't mean to shock you by saying global warming I hope I didn't ruin your
day with those two fucking words let me say climate change you can fucking relax
a little bit.
Still understand why they say that climate change.
It's like wouldn't Halliburton changed its fuckin name right.
Well they changed it to peaches and cream.
I can't fucking remember.
Anyways
I was just thinking that like the more like severe the weather is gonna get like
what will that mean.
You know like we can expect some crazy storms we've never fucking seen before.
I wonder if they took that into consideration when they built that goddamn
thing.
Then all of a sudden you know
we're going to start getting like like steroid era Mark McGuire era of fucking.
You know hurricanes
you know and this is going to be a category 19 and you're up there taking a
fuckin bath.
Watching this shit roll in it.
You're going to go right out that fucking window in that tub.
All the way down to the fucking pavement.
But what a way to go.
That poor son thing.
It'd be like the cartoons where you try to get the bathwater back into the
fucking tub.
It will be a hell of a death.
I honestly think if there is a God you know he would fuck and take extra time.
He would take extra time with you just being like like just watching the game
film of your death going
I'm just being like you know I've seen people die since the beginning man.
I hate this.
This this is this is what this is this is definitely I've never seen this one
before.
I've never seen somebody
in a bathtub at 13 out of 50 feet.
I don't know.
I don't know why I'm obsessed with that fuckin building it's just I don't know.
There was just something about the fact that they can't sell the one underneath
that is the funniest shit ever because who the fuck is gonna pay eighty five
million dollars and still have somebody living above and boy who you fucking
knock it off about their
I mean what am I paid for you.
Anyways how about those Red Sox huh.
How about those Red Sox.
But you know something they went deep deep.
They're undefeated.
They won five in a row undefeated this month.
All right.
And I went on the I went on the old Internet there.
Right.
And
I see.
I looked up the standings the baseball standings yet.
That that that was it.
But it ended at that.
That that was the baseball won right.
This week in baseball.
Doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo Lula big bad day.
The little day to day
that ended up ordered auditable.
If you saw the highlights and actually heard an orchestra playing when I just
played it or tried to sing it be tremendous.
So.
The Houston Astros evidently are the other beasts of the American League.
I was all excited that we slept a White Sox had just realized that the forty one
in 68.
I guess it's not such a big deal.
Well we did what we were supposed to do.
We kick the shit out of a man.
We won six in a row gone eight to last ten picked up three games on them fucking
Yankees you see fucking Aaron judge thirty fifth home run today.
Had the same trajectory as a base hit 7 went out of the park telling you it's
like and Paul Bunyan come into the goddamn play
loving the Indians in first place they'd be great to see them win one.
Let's test my knowledge.
All right Red Sox last World Series 2013 Yankees 2009.
Tampa Bay never set out.
Shut the fuck up.
Baltimore Orioles 1983 Toronto Blue Jays.
They went back to back 92 93.
Cleveland Indians 1948.
Kansas City Royals 20.
15.
Last year was a Cubs right.
Minnesota Twins 19.
Detroit 1984.
Chicago White Sox 2005.
Houston Astros never say.
Shut the fuck up.
Seattle Mariners never said Shut the fuck
so childless Los Angeles Angels 2000.
Two Texas Rangers.
You know what never said that.
Oakland eighty nine.
WASHINGTON centers never set out shut the fuck up.
Miami Marlins.
Was it 2003.
Atlanta Braves as ninety five New York Mets.
Every Red Sox fan knows that 1986 Philadelphia Phillies 2008.
Cubs 2016.
Milwaukee Brewers never set out.
Shut the fuck up.
St.
Louis Cardinals.
Oh shit I don't know this one they always win the fucking thing.
Was in 2006 or they wanted this decade.
Pittsburgh Pirates.
I don't know 70 one.
The Reds was nineteen ninety.
The Dodgers was eighty eight.
Colorado Rockies never.
Arizona Diamondbacks 2001.
The one time ever rooted for the Yankees because it was right after 9/11 I was
like Al gives a fuck.
I root for San Diego Padres never.
San Francisco Giants I want to say they wanted 2010 2012 and 2014 is that right.
15 was a royal 16 was a Cubs.
Yeah I'd say 20 40 years I bet.
For some he doesn't fucking watch baseball.
Was that boring to you.
I'm sorry.
Let me let me know if that was boring enough.
Let me get to one of the most exciting parts of this podcast.
Listening to me read out loud all right.
Here we go.
We got one two three four one two three four one two three four.
To think about that the other day when somebody had a doorbell like that when I
had a paper route when I was a kid I thought that that meant they were rich.
They didn't just go paying Mongo a
fuckin dentist drill one if they actually had the one that went ding dong ding
dong ding dong ding dong.
So where does that answer the door before it ended.
Then they're fucking looking at you all right.
Oh look who's here.
But oh Popal beyond D beyond D taking a bath at two thousand feet.
Doo doo doo doo.
Me and D me undies.
Oh getting a hooker I'm in dusky Gaza.
God.
Ninety five million bucks.
I'm fucking lonely I'm banging hookers and I gave him a pair of hooker me undies
and their policies are velvety soft.
Sorry.
All right.
You want to look good in your underwear.
What do you be comfortable right.
But that perfect balance is hard to find.
Don't sacrifice style or comfort.
Check out my undies.
August is national underwear month.
What did they have to pay to get that.
I mean
this is National Get a fucking job Marty.
They always have something.
This is international it is like.
A national fucking blueberry pancake day.
Yeah I'm so fucking sick of saying I had to look that up just in a place in my
house where I can't get internet.
By the way who the fuck knew the Dodgers would playing as well as I did.
You know because they think if you don't have spectrum you can't fucking watch a
mother.
August is national underwear month and to celebrate Beyond undies is jerkin me
undies is making it easier than ever to try.
The world's most comfortable underwear by giving you a risk free guarantee all
national underwear month long.
If you don't love your me undies they're free.
I love that keep a man.
We don't want to back me undies gets it.
Do I return them and they just go gross and they hang up on you.
Keep up beyond these are made from Len zig micro modal model a sustainably
sourced naturally soft fabric that's proven to be three times softer than
cotton.
How did they do that.
Did they tickle somebodies ball bag with each one.
No.
While he laughed a little more with Mike three times as much micro mode out is
an all natural breathable eco friendly fabric extruded from Austrian beech trees
that actually inhibits odor.
You know he would be into just too fucking smart times sometimes.
Who the fuck figured out to do that.
Eco friendly fabric.
Okay that means it's biodegradable extruded from Austrian beech trees that
actually inhibits odor.
So you'll see you had like 10 subjects with smelly balls and like you fucking
smell their balls J.
Christ and then you put that on we like you know it's not as bad.
No stinky undies just soft and cool and cozy.
Male host read this line and for the fellas you had for their families.
Me on these diamonds seemed pouch cradles your jewels gives you stuff the
support it needs without feeling too tight.
Female hosts read this and further ladies me on these features soft black theme
that minimizes slippage gross without sacrificing style pussy lips coming out
there and they're super
and every cut bikini thong boy short or cheeky brief.
What the fuck is that.
What's a cheeky brief is that a fucking some sort of English clamp.
It's simple if you don't love your me undies they're free CTA whatever that
means.
Now until August 30 first get 20 percent off your first pair plus free shipping
at me these dot com slash br.
That's me undies these dot com slash bra had me undies dot com slash br nuclear.
Nuclear nuke dealer.
I just liked it better.
Pro Flowers.
Pillow fight was mother fucker.
Hey there's no reason to get anybody flowers this month.
That's why you do it.
You know hey fellas you want to shut her up you're sick or saying there's no
spice in the relationship.
Get a bouquet of roses bouquet of roses.
Right.
I don't like roses.
I always get the fucking yellow ones.
Tulips tulips are great.
They brighten up the fucking room.
They actually smell nice.
You know what I mean.
I love the tulips.
You get in a nice yellow ones right.
It reminds them of the fucking J Lo diamond right.
Kobe's wife the diamond she got.
That's what they remember.
You know what I mean.
All right don't Tucker.
I almost fuckin went too far in that one.
I was gonna talk about where you then put the flowers in what you use as a face
and I'm not going to do that because I'm going to be a little more classy.
All right throw flowers talk about the last time he spontaneously surprised
someone with something completely unexpected and how it felt.
I know I try
I try to fuckin surprise my wife I can't.
She's too perceptive.
She figures everything out.
It's fucking unbelievable.
I can't even tell this story.
It's too fucking embarrassing.
I came to tell you but like you I had my fucking way I moved something around
and it was just something sitting on the windowsill in a room full of 5000
knickknacks and it was literally there for 20 minutes.
She came while she goes.
What is the blah blah blah.
The one on the fucking window sills and I just went like
like you know fuck you fuck you for being so goddamn perceptive all the time.
You have another fucking guy in the house it takes me three days before I
realize that he wasn't a plumber.
All right Pro Flowers wants to help you surprise someone for no reason.
All the while also surprising you with a special deal for my listeners get 20
percent off any fucking god damn computer.
So 20 percent off any unique summer Rose bookie's rose bouquets bouquets
bouquets or any other book bouquet boutique for two on twenty nine dollars and
when.
Said it too many times I can't hear the word anymore.
They're colorful rainbow roses are always a hit if you aren't sure what to send
someone Pro Flowers bouquets that I said are guaranteed to stay fresh for at
least 7 days or your money back and your control and you control the delivery
date Pro Flowers gives you more bloom for the buck.
Big beautiful flowers with stems for your money with more stems for your money
to get 20 percent off your summer roses or any other bouquet of twenty nine
dollars or more go to Pro Flowers dot com and use my promo code bar at checkout.
That's Pro Flowers dot com and cold br.
Don't wait to make somebody stay.
You know when I was a kid you just make them a mixtape like you boombox with the
fuckin side by side tapes.
You know that's what you do.
That's what you do.
All right.
Alex Alex.
You're unique.
You walk like anyone else talk like anyone else chirp chirp or sleep like anyone
else.
So why is your mattress why is your mattress one size fits all.
Because a truly customized mattress will cost you five to ten thousand fucking
dollars until now.
Go to Helix Sleep dot.com.
Answer a few simple questions and they'll run a 3D biomechanical model model of
your body through the proprietary algorithms they developed with the help of the
world's leading Iraq comics and biomechanics experts.
The result the most comfortable mattress you've ever slept on and a robot being
built in your exact image.
How its customers report a 30 percent improvement in overall sleep quality and
for couples they customize each side of the mattress.
Who's getting who the love is slowly die.
Why not fuck and you know begin your divorce by getting two different kinds of
mattresses and one begin your separate lives with your own customized side of
your mattress your mattress arrives at your door in about a week and shipping is
100 percent free and then after a while you get that little divider.
You know up in first class you guys ever get bumped up.
Greatest fuckin thing they'll ever happen to grab.
You know what.
Short of Jesus coming back and you find out that you did enough fucking good
deeds that you get saved or whatever your religion is.
Mohammed comes back and does something.
Fuckin Abraham Buda L.
Ron Hubbard whoever you whoever you wait for whoever you wait and for comes back
okay.
The only thing that's the only thing better than if that's shit's true right.
The only thing better is fuckin you know that little you get pumped up to first
class.
You know that little fuckin divider you know and you fly cross country next to
something for six hours.
You don't say one fuckin word to each other.
All right.
If you want to experience that at home you get a customized mattress either side
that's the same thing.
In turn your loved one into a complete stranger.
Your mattress arrives at your door in about a week and shipping is free.
That's why everyone from GQ magazine to Forbes are all talking about Helix
Sleep.
You have 100 nights to try it out and if you don't love it they'll pick it up
for free and give you a 100 percent refund no questions asked.
Go to Helix leap dot coms Landsberg get fifty dollars off your order that's
Halleck sleep talk com side bar he likes sleep dot com slash burn.
And lastly but not least Lee stamps dot com the headliner they always go on
last.
No one can follow this Reed It's nice it's quick it's the sync.
Usually no stumble over it.
OK.
I'm like the post office stamps dot com never closes.
Shots fired.
Unlike those pussies down the street we keep going.
This is the 24 hours of Lamont's fuckin shipping print postage for letters or
packages at your convenience 24/7.
Keywords slash descriptors convenient easy reliable and flexible.
That's how I'm gonna sell it guys.
I'm going to use one of those adjectives each.
Each sentence stamp dot.com brings all the services of the US Post Office right
to your fingertips.
Jesus.
That's convenient buy and print official U.S. postage for any letter any package
any class of mail using your own computer and printer.
Wow that's easy.
Stamps dot com makes it easy.
Fuck I just said that they'll send you a digital scale that automatically
calculates exact postage while that's reliable stamps dot com will even help you
decide the best class of mail.
On your needs.
Jesus that's flexible.
I use stamps dot com any time I'm fucking selling posters I'm gonna whore myself
out.
I use stamps dot com and I'm a moron.
I can figure it out so can you.
Right now you too can enjoy the stamps to com service for the special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale without long term
commitments.
Go to stamps dot com click on the microphone at the top of the page and type in
bar that stamps dot com into bar stamps dot com.
Never go to the post office again right.
We're done right.
We get through it all.
Beautiful beautiful beautiful.
20 minutes to go 20 minutes to go.
I talk about everything I wanted to talk about.
Then I mentioned Paul Versace has a standup special that all things comedy
network is gonna be producing our first standup special and the buzz on the road
is verses out there killing it like I knew he was gonna be all right.
August 13th at the Tarrytown Theatre in beautiful Tarrytown New York.
Picturesque.
Tom Hanks fucking Sleepless in Seattle looking fuckin place right.
Me and.
My dad Damn this fucking computer
fucking screen keeps shutting off me.
Pete Davidson may get this back on me.
MEP Davidson will be will be the sort of the masters of ceremony will be warming
me up going out on stage together giving each other shit trying out new jokes
fucking around I'm going to try to come out there in between shows that I want
to slow down the taping but I will definitely get out there saying whatever you
got take some pictures or whatever I'll try to move it along
or whatever you know whatever I can do to to fucking interact.
We have a few seats left.
I want to sell this thing out.
It's really important night for Paul and the All Things Comedy Network.
So I'd appreciate it if he got the time.
You want to listen to you know some comedy come on down.
August 13th All right.
Plowing ahead and I'll be at the Count Basie theater this weekend out in Jersey
out new Julie.
Red Bank New Jersey
which is really beautiful.
I might go to Asbury Park during the day I've no idea what I'm going to do
because I usually stay in the city.
I think I'm going to fuckin stay as somewhere out in Jersey.
You know maybe a call fucking what's his face Vinny brand Vinny brand has a
boat.
I'm terrified of the ocean going to go out in the fuckin ocean with a goddamn
club owner.
Why not.
All right.
Okay.
Here we go.
The properly with North Korea.
Dear Ronald McDonald balls.
North Korea is a serious threat to East Asia and now too good a portion of the
world.
I understand that.
So what.
So are we.
You know.
If you're gonna play this game you know what I mean like like everybody that
said the Patriots cheated if you're gonna play that game then you got to see the
cheating that you're doing.
Correct.
Am I nuts here.
Am I crazy.
Yes the missile test the other day was a ballistic missile but they can put a
nuclear weapon on it as well.
OK so can we we already we already have ours ready to go their latest test puts
most of the US all of Europe and a good portion of Africa within range of their
weapons.
Yes and all of those places are in range of our weapons and Russia's weapons
so
you know I mean look I'm not saying it's great that this guy has this fucking
thing but just imagine if he had what we had.
What the fuck would we be doing.
Wouldn't we be doing the same fucking thing.
Well we've got to get some stuff here.
He's making that shit because we got our shit.
Right.
It's like when the Yankees started spending 200 million fucking dollars the Red
Sox had to spend one night.
That's what happens.
And if they are actually able to successfully launched from a submarine as they
are attempting to do this.
This not only increases the range but can potentially dramatically increase the
amount of time we have to respond.
If they were to launch a missile what would happen sir.
That's it.
Everybody knows there's no end game to this shit.
Okay it's okay.
It's gonna be over
we would have time to respond.
Don't you remember what the fuck was it war games.
I can't believe how seriously people are fucking taking this shit.
I don't think this guy's out of his fuckin mind in North Korea.
All right.
I'm just so fucking sick of.
Having to turn on the TV and have somebody has to try.
It's like news now is just scared the shit out of somebody and offered no
fucking solutions and then normal people just sit there screaming at each other
to the point that this fucking dope is taking the time to turn my podcast which
is supposed to be a break from all of that shit.
Which is why I just say silly shit about it.
You turning this into Meet the Press
if that fucking asshole shoots one off poignant right at my house because I
don't want to survive it.
I don't give a fuck.
All right.
We have no one to blame but ourselves.
We're fucking defective.
If human beings were cars we would all be recalled.
All right.
We do not handle a position of power well and this is what the fuck happens all
right.
We're fearful fucking lunatics.
Who for some stupid reason were given the ability to fucking intimidate nerds so
they would build all this shit for us and now here we are.
Here we are.
All right.
North Korea also has the highest percentage of slaves in the world.
Fully like you care sir.
Like you give a shit.
Fully four point four percent of its population is enslaved.
That is approximately one point one million.
Sir I am on an apple fucking computer right now and I'm sure you typed yours on
an Apple computer too.
Those people are jumping out of the factory.
They're their fucking slaves all this shit that I'm wearing was made in
sweatshops.
Like what are we doing now.
Now we're gonna fudge the fucking numbers so these people look like they're out
of their minds but everybody else is fucking OK.
This is like commie countries are like community colleges where they will figure
out what their number one and so they can fuck and put it in their pamphlet.
OK.
Let's read some more fucking depressing information.
This is why I don't watch the news
today that it did.
And that doesn't even mention the network of concentration camps across the
nation and the people getting less than subsist
less than subsistence levels of daily calories.
Well I mean they're also not allowed to trade with anybody are they you know
they really can't get their shit going right.
I mean part of that is us trying to force them into giving in to get them
forever twenty ones in Starbucks there isn't that right.
I mean I might be wrong.
So I fuckin watch sports I watch sports I listen to music.
OK.
I block all this shit out so I'm sure I mispronounce some words here to put that
into perspective.
About three hundred eighty eight thousand slaves were shipped to North America
from fifteen twenty five to eight nine 1866.
It's obviously a huge issue.
Well how do you how do you put that in perspective without telling me what the
population of Korea is.
And also three hundred eighty eight thousand people back in but between 15 25 in
1866 was a way more significant portion of the population than it is today.
Correct.
So I don't know what you're saying there sir but I do know that whenever we have
an issue with the country all of a sudden we pretend to care about its people.
Unfortunately there isn't any easy solution to the problem.
Even if China withdraws their support and the regime regime collapses you're
still looking at a potential civil war in a nation with nuclear weapons.
Let's just hope people smarter than you are I can find a different solution to
the problem and then they won't.
There's only one solution.
Gotta go in there and get them.
Keep up the good work.
I love hearing you talk about us how awesome it is to be a parent instead of
constant talk about how hard it is.
As a dad of two boys there are obviously days when I feel like ripping out what
little hair I have left.
But the vast vast majority of the time is just awesome.
Look at this.
He was actually just informing me and I got all fucking defensive because all
this week people said that I said new killer instead of new clear.
Yes sir I realize he's out of his fucking mind.
I realize that person's out of his fucking mind.
The guy before him his dad was out of his fucking mind OK.
Trump is out of his fucking mind.
I'm out of my fucking mind.
OK.
Nobody should have weapons other than your fucking fists and whatever you can
grab in the kitchen.
That's ideally that's what that would be better.
All right.
I think I don't understand why war is legal but it is.
So this is the game that we play with each other and it is fucking inevitable
that one day somebody is going to go Martin Sheen dead zone
and what are you gonna do.
Yeah out.
See people this is why I have all four sports packages because I don't want to
know about this shit.
I don't want to fuckin sit here and watch the news and have them scare the
living shit out of me that now this is going to happen.
You know and some flies going to bite me and then I have a baby with a little
head.
Somebody else is going to fucking blow me up.
Yeah just I just I don't want to talk about this.
OK.
Trying to keep it light on the podcast here.
Let's just make this just laugh at me not being able to pronounce words don't
bring actual facts into this podcast.
All right girls softball team punished.
Hey there billy batting glove.
Did you hear about the girls softball team that was removed from the World
Series because of a picture of some of the players flicking off the camera on
social media.
One of the girls on the team is the daughter of a family friend.
It's fucking brutal.
Yeah I mean I don't know.
I don't know what I don't understand social media.
I'm kind of over it.
Other than for business purposes.
I don't just don't think it's a good thing that should've just been a funny
picture that they all took shared amongst themselves.
But now you upload it and everybody sees it and you know somebody is going to
get offended.
Let me guess.
Were they the best.
Well they probably were the number one seed.
This sounds like one of those bad news bears things.
They were removed from the World Series.
Well
well you know how you know people are there trying to make money they make money
off that World Series is a national thing.
I don't know.
It's like the Colin Cameron Dick thing everybody's fucking flipping out and
immediately thinking that this guy's not getting hired because of racism.
It's like the NFL is a fucking Corporation.
Okay you know what they give a fuck about money.
Now look if he was trying to get a coaching job or own a team then yeah I would
say racism would be more obvious but like what he does most of the league is
black.
Doing.
Okay.
Their thing is they're such cheap fucking cunts
they would rather lose a fucking game.
They probably have an algorithm going like OK if we get this guy and he wins a
few more games.
How many jerseys will we sell versus the amount of people who won't buy a jersey
because we signed this guy and I swear to God if if if we'll sell a fucking
Jersey less by signing a guy who would actually make us a better fuckin team I
swear they will decide not to sign the guy.
I don't.
I'm not saying this isn't racism involved but it's really it's fucking economics
and what these fucking corporations try to do is they they don't want any
bullshit they want smooth fucking water that's what they want everybody fucking
just tow the fucking line that's what they want and I'll tell you all these
fucking groups that are trying to make change.
No that shit.
Which is why they always complain to the advertisers because the advertisers
will then pull.
Sponsorship from TV shows they'll do it from fucking podcasts.
Everybody knows that.
So the NFL is a corporation.
So that's what they're doing.
I don't know what the fuck league these girls are in but I'm sure they have some
sort of stupid conduct thing that they're trying to you know
trying to uphold.
Yeah.
It's fucking stupid.
It's also fucking stupid to upload that picture.
I mean how many of these dumb stories are you going to see where people get
offended by absolutely nothing and it's something happens right.
That's unfortunate.
It's unfortunate.
All right.
Trent Reznor This is like a way more serious podcast than I ever want to do.
I don't know.
I don't know I have to do it.
I must just start making up shit here I try to read the news but it's just all
depressing.
Although the funny one was all this shit coming out about Lady Diana now I just
don't understand how new evidence.
Twenty years later they're fine.
They found out that fucking she was listening to Prince Charles jerking off
talking to some other lady on a toilet.
Did somebody have that tape for fucking 20 years going hey to listen to this I
swear to God don't tell anybody I have this I'm going to release it when the
time is right and then you just hear the echoing sound of Prince Charles going
Roy again putting your ass your arse.
All right Trent Reznor article A Billy boy Billy boy he thought you could relate
to this.
Trent Reznor talks about what it's like to meet his parents kids you meant to
say is kids parents while having a body of work with lyrics like I want to fuck
you like an animal.
Yeah I read that article but
never underestimate the power of celebrity and especially I know he's an older
dad.
So maybe they don't even know what his fucking music is but you know I wouldn't
give a shit I sang I downloaded that focus so I fucking loved his stuff.
That shit came out of that album blew my fucking mind.
I believe that's Trent fuckin Reznor hey sweetheart that's Trent fuckin Reznor.
I wouldn't give a shit you know but it's gotta be weird.
But then there's of course the people that don't like it you know the people
there were like the for each club
and you know what Adam
they wanted to fuck someone like an animal and he expressed it
all right.
Court girlfriend cheating after joining the military and I legally can't leave
her
what she's a girlfriend.
All right.
Dear Billy ball balls.
He's a good this week you guys usually you know.
Lately there's been a little drought is a fucking funny this week all right.
Greetings from Scotland.
Recently I quit my well-paying job to join the British Royal Marines.
My girlfriend of four years was very hesitant and didn't want me to leave.
But it had been a dream of mine since I was 14.
I sat down a week before leaving and gave her the opportunity to separate my
girlfriend for years is very hesitant and didn't want me to leave but we'd been
dreamers and unfortunately I sat down with her a week before leaving and gave
her the opportunity to separate on good terms and maybe continue our
relationship.
When I had finished my mandatory four years service.
But if we stayed together but we stay if we stayed together and she cheated she
would be dead to me.
I'm half Sicilian by the way.
She chose to stay.
The fact that you were given the option to leave.
I mean how much you give a shit about this woman.
I was in for just over four weeks and fell during a run in a six six month
server guys stood on my leg breaking my tibia in two places.
Oh fuck.
I was given the choice of staying in medical custody on base and rejoined
training when I had healed or leaving for a year.
I chose to leave so I could spend more time with my girlfriend.
Oh.
Oh I thought it would be a nice surprise to not tell her I was coming home.
Oh Jesus.
I arrived home around 9 p.m.
on Thursday.
Oh my God.
To find my girl oh jesus choking on some guy's dick.
Wow.
So what did you throw your fucking crutches at him.
Naturally my instinct was to beat the shit out of the guy but I'm not too mobile
with a pair of crutches.
I forced the two out of my house and kept my promise of your dead to me by
changing the locks.
The next morning and blocking her number and social media accounts around 2
weeks later I received the letter from a lawyer saying that if I don't take her
back she can legally take half of all my assets including the house my mother
left me in her will because we had been together for more than two years
what I thought you had to be married.
But lo and behold the British justice system does me another solid.
I could understand if I was away on tour from 9 months that she cheated but for
weeks fucking for weeks you gotta be fucking kidding me.
So I just take the loss and leave this dumb whore.
Do I take her back and try to forget the fact that she took the first
opportunity she had to jump on jump another guy's bone your bones your input
would be great and maybe can put a funny twist on this fucked up opportunity for
your listeners.
Do you need to get a fucking lawyer.
You need to get that bitch out of your life and get a fucking lawyer.
That's what you need to do.
All right.
That's one of the dumbest laws I've ever heard in my life and that's going to
cause.
That's going to cause people to make some really fucked up decisions.
If someone can screw on that fucking bad.
All right.
Over here.
If the statutory.
Statutory rape.
What is it.
What is the fucking law when you've been illegally married.
That's squatter's rights what the fuck is it.
I don't know.
Over here it's like you gotta be living with somebody for like 7 year depending
on the state.
And at that point they considered it so dumb that she's entitled to half his
shit especially if she's not making any money and you're fucking paying for
everything you know.
It's fucking ridiculous.
What a fucking cunt.
You know what I mean.
I mean how many fuckin stories do they do out there about men beating women and
how awful men are to fucking women right.
Which obviously they've got to shine a light on that but look at this she's
she's gonna just fucking whore.
Who sucked this other guy's dick.
Doesn't could care less about taking half of the house that your mother left you
Oh my God what a fucking cunt.
Dude I would get a lawyer.
I would get Oh my God I would get a fuckin lawyer.
What a fucking piece of shit dude like I only I can't even.
This is like making me angry that someone could do that to somebody
what kind of a piece of shit.
The kind of person that fucking blows somebody for we said.
But even then there's plenty of women that would do that.
There's plenty of fucking women that would do that.
They wouldn't take your fucking house.
They were raised right.
They get caught sucking addicted guy.
You know fair enough and they leave
Jesus cry.
We get a lawyer sir.
I would get a lawyer and I would fuckin fight this thing find some fucking thing
that Oh my God.
The advice that I want to give you I can't say over this because I'll be liable.
Okay.
And it's like
all right let me tell let me tell the fucking little story here.
I can't I can't do it.
I can't tell the story because I'll get in fucking trouble.
I won't serve.
You know what I will get a lawyer and handle it legally.
Don't do anything fucking crazy.
All right.
Jesus Christ.
What I can't do.
I'll tell you right there man you you met one for the ages.
That's a first ballot Hall of Fame count.
If I ever fucking heard of one.
Good Lord.
I could see if she caught you and then out of vindictiveness then did that that
you know they'd be like well you know what the fuck.
But she's gonna do that and then take half your fuckin house.
And you know it kills me when she tells the story.
She.
I'm not saying she'll play that she won't be in the wrong.
I mean that's a fucking psychopath.
Thank God you didn't breed with her man.
Jesus fucking Christ
Jesus Christ.
Well you know what.
Thank you for your service sir.
You know what these whores can take everything you got.
There's nothing you can fucking do about it.
That's how the laws are set up and I gotta be honest with you dude.
You know worst case scenario if she takes you off half your house and have to
shit.
Even still considering what the fuck they can do to you.
You actually got off easy
easier than a lot of guys did.
But Jesus Christ
can I apologize for this podcast.
I don't want to get involved in world politics.
I don't want to talk about North Korea.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
You don't know me.
For the 18 people that are going to take any of this shit fucking seriously I
don't give a shit.
Let's just keep it to correcting my fucking spelling shall we.
I'm going to end this fucking podcast on an upbeat note.
It's Joe de Rose's birthday today.
God damn it.
He's coming home from fucking Amsterdam.
I'm Guy.
Happy
birthday Joey Rose is.
Happy birthday Joey Rose.
No way.
I came.
I can't sing the song.
If you ever heard this fucking songs we sing to each other.
I mean just I'm trying to think of a group that wouldn't be offended by it.
I know the one group in particular.
I literally can't even sing the fuck.
This is just whole thing just went off the fucking rails.
This whole podcast went off the rails because that was one that was such a
fucking do you know what I did.
You know because I've been stuck in the writers room and I haven't been going
out doing stand up and seeing people and having stories to tell you what I do
before I get on the podcast.
Now as I just click on Google news and it's just the most horrific shit.
You know that fucking ride that broke in Ohio fucking 18 year old kid died.
Kid was born in nineteen ninety nine died going to a fucking amusement park.
Somebody blew up a mosque.
Tried to fucking Minneapolis.
I don't understand how people sit there and they watch CNN and Fox and all that
shit just like what does it do for you to stay informed.
I don't have a fucking
I want to be fucking.
I don't want to say it.
Fuck I would be doing I.
It's just not fun anymore.
I get it.
You know what I gotta do.
I'm going to watch I promise you guys I'm just gonna watch sports between now
and Thursday and I am going to do something.
I'm going to go to a mall or something.
I'll just make fun of fat people when I get back.
I apologize for the heaviness of this podcast.
All right go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you on Thursday over there.